[Music]
dave is with us in santa maria
california hi dave how are you
hi i'm fine dave i'm john thank you for
taking my call sure i'm 75. my wife is
74. my home is paid off uh we're six
hundred thousand we have six hundred
thousand savings and
investments uh we've been debt free for
15 years
we just purchased this a half ton pickup
to take our rv and travel around the
country
and in closing the rv
the finance manager wanted to put a 2500
extra fee on top of a extended warranty
i said no
and then my wife and
the finance manager both were on my case
because i wasn't gonna spend twenty five
hundred dollars for that extended
warranty
in three days the wife loves me uh but
she still kinda has a real sound joint
every now and then making a comment
about we should have got the warranty i
said i don't feel like it honey we got
the truck let's move on
uh kind of oh you did not buy it
huh you did not buy the warranty
no i didn't you stood your ground
against the finance manager and your
wife way to go dave
you win the argument my house
yeah you win the argument my house tell
my wife yeah you win the argument let me
tell you what to tell your wife okay
extended warranties are a freaking scam
the finance manager would have made more
money on selling you that warranty than
selling you that truck
okay
here's the numbers
50 of that 2500 was going in that
dealership's pocket as a commission
now let's back up a second and you and i
open up an extended warranty company for
a second okay you want to go with me on
this trip let's pretend we're going to
open an extended warranty and was this
on the f-150 or on the rv
f-150 okay so what we would do if we
were going to sell extended warranties
on an f-150 which by the way is a fine
freaking truck okay but let's just say
we wanted to do that and we would study
the f-150s and say okay out of a
thousand of them the items that we're
going to cover with the warranty break
14 times on this one and 18 times on
this one and 26 times on this one and so
our cost per 1000 f-150s is x
over actual repairs does that make sense
okay if we're going to open a warranty
company we gotta our cost of doing
business is fixing the truck right
right and we've got really good
mathematical data on the probability of
that actually occurring and what each
car costs on average to cover you wanna
know what that number is it's 12
of the
2500. in other words out of 2 500
about
280 bucks is the actual estimated
repairs of the average f-150 during the
warranty coverage
yeah well where's the rest of the money
going well i already told you 50 plus
percent goes to commissions and the rest
of it goes to profit for the warranty
company and or overhead for the warranty
company so you would have paid twenty
five hundred dollars to actually get
about two hundred and eighty dollars
worth of coverage
which you should self insure through you
have six hundred thousand freaking
dollars you are a genius you smelled a
rat and you stood up for your rights you
win
your wife was looking for peace of mind
let me tell you where peace of mind
comes from 600 grand in the bank not a
warranty
rock star well done dave you get the
teller you won the argument but be very
careful how you telling that he's been
married a while he knows how to do this
yeah that one wouldn't already be my
wife so there you go
it's not a matter of loving your wife i
love my wife and she's wrong sometimes
did you tell her that
no
not like that i don't i said i just said
how long i've been married 39 years i'm
gonna tell her gently but i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna also say you were right we
should have got the warranty because the
warranty is stupid they're scams
extended warranties are awful never buy
them people
man i i i hope both of my new dave
friends are married this time next week
they'll be great that'd be great yeah
well no i mean you got it
though when you're in the dealership the
guy's the dealership i was having a cow
you know why is 1250 bucks out of his
pocket well then he he he did whatever
he sails he wants to do he got the wife
involved oh yeah what a scum he thought
he had him what a scumber man thought he
had him let me tell you you get 600 you
know how you get 600 grand at retirement
by not doing stupid
smelling a rat like that oh man so i
went into an appliance store one time
with sharon we had to have a new washer
and dryer
and um
i thought the guy had recognized me the
way he was talking and it's a it's a
part of my world sometimes i recognize
sometimes i don't and it's okay either
way i'm not it's not like ego but the
way he was carrying on i thought he knew
who we were but anyway i just so we're
like i want to get have you got one with
a den in it and you know ha ha i want to
get a deal no i don't okay okay we'll
take that one and he goes well you need
to get the extended warranty on it and i
started laughing because i thought he
knew like who it was he knew i stood how
i stood on it and he's like no no no
really you need to get this and i'm like
no no no i really don't then i start to
realize he doesn't know who i am and he
has no idea he's just trying to sell me
an extended warranty i'm like no dude i
don't i don't buy extended warranties
and then the guy goes
dave ramsey does
and i'm like why yes
and he goes yeah dave ramsey comes in
and buys stuff all the time and he
always puts an extended warranty on it
[Laughter]
i would have paid money to see you and
sharon's face right there i'm looking at
my wife and she looks at me and i said
well i have it on good authority that
dave ramsey does not come into this
store i am positive and by extended
warranties and he goes oh yeah i mean he
bows up so i hand him my real i pull up
i pull out my driver slices and i hand
it to him
and he goes oh
bleep
busted and starts backpedaling oh mr ed
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i said listen
dude
i said sharon we need to leave because
i'm really angry right now and this man
is using our name inappropriately and
i'm afraid i'm going to say something
that that will be a true dave ramsey
story that he can use later and we need
to leave quickly oh we'll do something
we'll fix you up man it's no problem no
problem no problem and so we left yeah
and we went to lowe's and bought them at
lowe's yep and um the next day the
manager of the store called the office
and and said can you come over here and
i went oh i said sure went over there he
goes man we looked it up we've got a
dave ramsey on file but he lives in
another city nearby that does have
extended warranties and we've been
telling everybody it was you and we were
wrong and we've sent an email to all the
stores telling people not to do that
anymore please don't talk about us on
the radio
hey i like the fact that when he said
would you come by because i would have
said no man i got stuff to do i like
that you said yeah i'll be right over
well this was i was having too much fun
yeah yeah it's like yeah i got to see
what this is and i went and bought stuff
from that other guy many times after
that i bought several things from it
that was my new friend that was a good
movie he's my new friend